It's going to try and get it working.
It's like Fonzie. That's exactly what I thought.
And there's a reference that will be lost. And most of the audience, Oh,
we've got two stations. Fantastic. So the business end is actually going to be,
all this is doing is amplify and stop at a session down there, each voice.
So this is a London stairs. She was called. Absolutely.
And this is all coming out of a penny,
tiny wire and a penny and a penny is acting as a diode rectifier on the signal.
And we are picking up a station called absolute radio all the way from London
on a piece of way, or hung out at my office, which is acting as an antenna.
And actually, if we didn't have this and we had a pair of headphones,
this thing would work with no power source.
Well, you're like a high powered physicist. What are you doing?
Messing around with this? So it all goes back about, um,
how many years would it be? 41 years, 41 years to this book,
this book was actually published in 1972.
And this is where for me, physics started my uncle.
Benny was a radio amateur,
really interested in shortwave radio and listening to shortwave radio and
building antennas, getting better signals. He and I, when I was about 10,
use this book to build something which is called a crystal radio.
So we've got a coil, which is an inductor. We've got a capacitor,
which we can choose. So we can change the capacitance, a diode,
which is something called a rectifier,
which means it only lets current flow one way and a pair of headphones.
Or indeed,
I used an ear piece exactly like this it's what's called a Pietro electric or a
crystally or piece. Is this the actual book or this is,
this is I really wish I had the actual book. I suspect if I had the actual book,
it wouldn't quite be in this good or quality.
There's a whole new series of Ladybird books by the way that some of you
might've seen, which are pretty good.
The zombie apocalypse mindfulness and best of
all, the student Lisa finds her revision timetable. Very tiring.
That is because it starts at 1:00 AM when she can be sure,
dear time television has definitely finished.
There were a spoof of these books that are, I learned a lot.
There was this one and this one and a whole host of other ones that basically
you use a plank of wood and we weren't even as technical as putting
screws in it, what you use instead,
what I would call thumbtacks or drawing pins.
And we just press those into the board and we wedge their component leads
underneath. So here we have our coil coil here, capacitor,
which is this thing.
I went down to our over-friendly electronics workshop and said,
I'd like an old style van capacitor because I want to recreate this.
And they went, Hey, you go fell.
And then I haunted through a few of these to find one with the good capacitance
on one that was actually working what they used to do. And for example,
these were also known, known as crystal radios,
but they were also known as foxhole radios and prisoners of war used to build
them in the, in the second world war.
And they couldn't get their hands on something like this.
So what the other thing you can do instead of changing the capacitance and
having a capacitance variable,
you can change the inductance and the way you do that is you have different what
are called taps on the coil.
So instead of connecting the diode right at the end,
you might connect it here or here or here or here.
And that allows you to change the frequency that you're detecting.
So when I initially built this all those years ago,
we used something which is called a Silicon diode important thing with this is
it only allows current to flow one way.
And so instead of it's sloshing back and forth like this,
it's just allowing it to flow in one direction as really,
really important in terms of being able to detect the signal and to pull out the
signal, to extract the signal, um, the music, the sound,
the voice from what's called the carrier rave, which is a radio wave itself.
The radio wave itself is a combination of what's called a carrier wave,
which is very high-frequency maybe a million times going back and forth,
maybe a million times,
a second electric field flipping back and forth at a megahertz.
And of course they, audio signal is much, much lower than that.
It's a tens of kilohertz.
And so this along with the other elements and the circuit pulls out the audio,
the music, the talk, whatever, from, from the overall radio wave.
Phil, when you're a boy, you said that you used, you used one of them.
What have you done today?
What I've done today? This is amazing. I can't believe this actually works.
So with a penny in the UK,
at least it's different in the U S don't my Wiki homework on this in the UK,
where you have a stainless steel and it's colder to copper,
but of course that copper oxidizes, and this is a fairly badly oxidized.
You can see even little patches of green stuff on this. Penny,
if you look carefully.
And the wonderful thing is just like Silicon copper oxide is something called a
semiconductor. And so with this type of diode,
what happens is you get two different types of, of Silicon one, which is doped,
what's called N-type and another, which is called dub pay type.
The doping changes the conductivity and you sandwich those together.
And when those two materials interact and mix to a certain extent,
what happens is that you get a barrier for electrons to flow in one direction
and not a barrier in the other direction. Now wonderfully,
you can also do the same thing with a metal on semiconductor contact.
And it's called a Schottky diode.
This is about the most rudimentary form of a shocky diode.
One can imagine its called a cat's whisker in that we've got a wire touching
very, very gently because we want to touch the oxide.
We don't want to dig through to hit the copper or the steel underneath because
then we'd short over the note. So we want to have a weak contact.
So we've got this thing in this wire on it's acting almost like a spring.
So it's so delicate, right? It's gone completely now.
So we've got to try and recover it. This might involve quite a lot of swearing.
Nope. And it goes.
Again. And so this is what they used to do.
Can you imagine being in the sort of trenches and your prisoner of war,
just moving this thing around or so frustrated,
you want to have some sort of icon.
What's happening.
Hit the table. So this contact here is moving ever of ever so slightly.
And so what I want to do is just jog it.
So it finds a nice spot on the penny where we've got a good.
Come on you pig
[inaudible].
Okay. So that's not great. So it depends on where you are in the penny.
[Inaudible].
Not bad. This is on a penny on a penny. When I first did this,
I think I got more excited than when I did it as a 10 year old.
Obviously those are recent Nobel prize. And I was just reading this blog,
which is in the dark by a guy called Peter colds.
But he's talking about the Princeton press conference for Jim peoples.
I'm sure you've done something on Jim Peebles recently Bridie and there's this
wonderful quote from peoples. My advice is not to him.
My advice is not to employ prizes and awards.
They will come or they want don't judge your career by the number by the counter
prices. We're in this for the joy of research, the fascination,
the love of science. That is the reward really. And honestly,
when this thing worked last night,
when I tried it for the first time I was jumping around the room. Um,
and I'm no quite a bit older than I was when I first made it.
But still there was still the same punching the air moment. Phil,
we've done videos before about your real research.
And one thing we always talk about is that tip of your microscope and how
sensitive it is, it reminds me exactly, but even better than up ready,
even better. Oh thank you for that wonderful unplanned segue.
This is one of the Silicon samples from or STM.
This is a sample one. And while both are two samples there,
both of which we've imaged with atomic resolution.
And what I'm going to do is take this and let's see if we can use one of these
Silicon samples. It should be easier than a penny, um,
to actually detect the signal because we've got a semiconductor and we've got a
metal, so, okay. We'll take that out.
I probably will never get it working again. Piece of Silicon.
This is going to replace the penny. So I just have to adjust
When enough pressure. So it sits under there, but not so much that it cracks.
Just bear with me. This is all as fiddly.
[Inaudible].
That's what we'd expect. It's suddenly conductor than a Trumpy owned penny.
So we should expect a better signal. Physics works,
sort of tuning a circuit. There's a signal. How's it gone?
I think there's another one back here. Notice no attention.
Pant to screening. This is about as Heath Robinson as a guts.
So that's our signal. That's our ground.
And I've just a couple of them together.
I wanted it to be as close as possible to what happened years ago.
Yeah.
Okay.
Come on right here. Place a song.
Ready?
Thank you. Absolute radio for being on exactly the right frequency of course,
because what you can do is you can work.
I want frequency of detecting from the inductance here and the capacitance here,
but um, I wish I planned it that much.
You can see from the really higgledy-piggledy wire.
And I didn't put a lot of effort into this and it worked.
It's a rock radio as well. It was very helpful.
[inaudible].
We didn't stop here. You can hear even more from Phil,
particularly on the topic of resonant frequency.
Notice I'm not driving at the amplitude stairs to same.
All I'm changing is the frequency.
Really important.
There were links on screen and in the video description and to see more videos,
including plenty more from Phil, check out everything on our channel,
60 symbols, or.
We can do what we're doing here and we can listen to it.